.
IT'S 5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY, AND
THIS IS "THE FIVE," LIVE FROM
FOX SQUARE.
IT IS DECISION DAY IN AMERICA
AFTER COUNTLESS HOURS OF
CAMPAIGNING AND CANDIDATES
FIGHTING TO WIN OVER VOTERS, IT
IS NOW TIME FOR YOU TO DECIDE.
THE FIRST POLLS CLOSING IN LESS
THAN AN HOUR FROM NOW, AND WHAT
HAPPENS TONIGHT COULD SEND
SHOCKWAVES ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
WASHINGTON AND THE REST OF THE
STATES ARE NOT GOING TO BE THE
SAME AFTER TONIGHT.
DEMOCRATS ARE BRACING FOR THE
WORST CASE SCENARIO.
A RED TSUNAMI, WIPING OUT THEIR
DELICATE GRIP ON THE HOUSE AND
THE SENATE.
REPUBLICANS VERY CONFIDENT AS
AMERICA GETS READY TO START
COUNTING.
>> WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A RED
WAVE ACROSS THIS COUNTRY.
Y'ALL ARE GOING TO MAKE IT
HAPPEN.
>> THIS RED WAVE, THE HEADWATERS
IN THE COMMONWEALTH OF VIRGINIA,
SWEEP ACROSS THE COMMONWEALTH
AGAIN.
>> I WANT YOU TO WATCH NANCY
PELOSI HAND ME THAT GAVEL.
>> PENNSYLVANIA SENDING A CLEAR
MESSAGE TO WASHINGTON.
WE WANT LESS RADICALISM AND MORE
BALANCE.
>> INFLATION CAME FROM JOE
BIDEN'S WHITE HOUSE.
>> THE PRESIDENT SAID THE
BIGGEST THREAT TO DEMOCRACY IS
VOTING FOR A REPUBLICAN.
NO.
THE BIGGEST THREAT TO DEMOCRACY
IS KEEPING HIM IN THE WHITE
HOUSE.
>> I'M TALKING ABOUT, NOT JUST
AN ELECTION, BUT WIN SO BIG THAT
IT SENDS A CLEAR MESSAGE THAT
WE'RE NOT GOING TO LET ANYONE
DESTROY OUR STATE AND OUR
COUNTRY.
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN PUTTING ON
HIS BEST FACE WHILE ADMITTING
HIS PARTY COULD BE IN FOR A
ROUGH NIGHT.
>> HOW ARE YOU FEELING?
>> I'M FEELING OPTIMISTIC, BUT
I'M ALWAYS OPTIMISTIC.
>> THE DEMOCRATS WIN THE HOUSE?
>> I THINK IT'S GOING TO BE
TOUGH.
I THINK WE CAN.
I THINK WE'LL WIN THE SENATE.
>> DEMOCRATS WILL HAVE TO DO
SOME SOUL SEARCHING IF THEY LOSE
BIG.
"WASHINGTON POST" COLUMNIST SAYS
THAT DEMOCRATS ARE DROWNING IN
DENIAL AS THEY APPEAR TO BE
HEADING TOWARD PAINFUL LOSSES.
FOR NEARLY TWO YEARS, DEMOCRATIC
LEADERSHIP HAS OFTEN PUSHED
ASIDE POLITICALLY INCONVENIENT
DEVELOPMENTS RATHER THAN FACING
THEM HEAD ON.
THEY'VE OFTEN TOLD THEMSELVES
STORIES THEY WANT TO CLEVE
INSTEAD OF STORIES THAT ARE
TRUE, AND MIGHT MOTIVATE THEM TO
CHANGE THEIR MESSAGING AND
POLICY DIRECTION.
TIM RYAN OF OHIO, HE WAS ON A
SHOW, ON ANOTHER NETWORK, AND
HE -- THIS IS HOW HE THINKS
IT'S GOING TO GO.
WATCH THIS.
>> TIM RYAN WITH HIS CLOSING
ARGUMENTS ON TONIGHT'S LAST
WORD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> WE'LL BRING IT HOME,
LAWRENCE.
>> GOT YOU.
>> WE'RE GOING TO BRING IT HOME.
>> HAROLD, BRING IT HOME ON
ELECTION NIGHT FOR US.
>> TIM RYAN IS THE MOST TALENTED
CANDIDATE THE DEMOCRATS PUT
FORWARD FOR THE SENATE THIS
YEAR.
I WISH HIM THE BEST TONIGHT.
WE'VE SAID IT WELL, WHATEVER
HAPPENS TONIGHT, DEMOCRATS TO
HAVE TO A RENDEZVOUS WITH
REALITY AROUND A NUMBER OF
ISSUES.
I HOPE REPUBLICANS SHIFT TOWARD
MORE PROBLEM-SOLVING.
I WAS ENCOURAGED TO HEAR LEADER
McCARTHY, THE MINORITY LEADER
IN THE HOUSE, WE'LL SUPPORT
UKRAINE, WE REALIZE ENERGY AND
THE BORDER, ISSUES AMERICANS
WANT TO ADDRESS AND WE'LL DO
THAT.
LET'S WAIT AND SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
THE PRESIDENT IS RIGHT, THIS IS
GOING TO BE A TOUGH NIGHT IN THE
HOUSE.
I'VE AGREED WITH THE
CONVENTIONAL THINKING, THAT
DEMOCRATS WILL HAVE A TOUGH,
TOUGH TIME.
IN THE SENATE, THIS IS STILL A
JUMP BALL.
THE POLLING IS STILL VERY TIGHT.
I'M GOING TO BE AS SURPRISED AS
ANYONE TO SEE WHAT THE RESULTS
ARE THIS EVENING.
ONE THING IS FOR CERTAIN, I WILL
ACCEPT THE RESULTS.
I WILL ENCOURAGE MY PARTY TO
WORK WITH WHICHEVER PARTY IS IN
THE MAJORITY, ENCOURAGE THIS
WHITE HOUSE TO DO THE SAME.
>> HAROLD DOES NOT BELIEVE
DEMOCRACY WILL DIE TONIGHT,
JUDGE.
>> DEMOCRACY LIVES.
>> WELL, YOU KNOW WHAT, YOUR
PRESIDENT THINKS SO, IF THE
DEMOCRATS DON'T WIN.
I KIND OF LICHEN THIS TO A
TRIAL.
>> OKAY.
>> THE JURY IS THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
THE ELECTORATE.
THE CANDIDATES GET TO MAKE THEIR
CASE, WITH EVIDENCE.
SO THE QUESTION IS THAT WHAT
EVIDENCE DID THEY PUT FORWARD
THAT MADE SENSE, THAT RESONATED,
THAT MADE -- YOU KNOW, THAT
REALLY WAS RELEVANT TO YOUR
LIFE?
THEN YOU HAVE CLOSING ARGUMENTS.
THE CLOSING ARGUMENTS OF JOE
BIDEN.
I MEAN, THEY MADE NO SENSE.
THE TRUTH IS THAT THE DEMOCRATS
DID NOT CONNECT WITH THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE ON THE ISSUE OF
SAFETY, CRIME, IMMIGRATION,
EDUCATION, INFLATION, THE
ECONOMY.
SO I THINK THE DISSIDENCE AND
THE MISALIGNMENT IS GOING TO BE
LOUD.
IT'S GOING TO BE ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
I THINK THAT AFTER AMERICANS
DELIBERATE AND AFTER THEY VOTE,
THAT VERDICT IS GOING TO BE ONE
THAT'S GOING TO BE VERY PAINFUL
FOR THE DEMOCRATS.
AT LEAST WE'VE GOT AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CHANGE THE COURSE
MIDTERM.
>> JESSE, THE PRESIDENT SAYS
HE'S AN OPTIMIST, HE'S
OPTIMISTIC, BUT YOU LISTEN TO
THE TONE, HE SOUNDED TIRED.
IT'S BEEN A LONG CAMPAIGN.
>> HE SOUNDED TIRED HIS WHOLE
CAREER.
MY MOM THINKS THERE'S GOING TO
BE A RED WAVE.
THAT'S HOW BIG IT'S GOING TO BE.
USUALLY IF YOU'RE IN POWER,
YOU'RE BRACING FOR THE MIDTERMS,
BUT YOU HAVE SOMETHING TO RUN
ON, SOMETHING TO PLANT YOUR
FLAG, AND SAY THIS IS WHAT WE
DID.
I STILL DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT FOR
THE DEMOCRATS.
THEY DON'T TALK ABOUT COVID.
THEY DON'T TALK ABOUT
INFRASTRUCTURE.
THEY NEVER BUILT ANYTHING.
THEY DON'T TALK ABOUT THE
ECONOMY.
THEY DIDN'T DO ANYTHING WITH THE
SO REPUBLICANS HAVE SUCH A BIG
ADVANTAGE.
THEY HAVE A SMORGASBORD OF
ISSUES TO RUN, IF THAT'S A REAL
WORD.
ALL THESE ISSUES CUT CRASS RACE,
GENDER, AGE LINES.
SO REPUBLICANS HAVE A HUGE
OPPORTUNITY TO GAIN A WHOLE NEW
SUBSECTION OF VOTERS, THEN
CAPITALIZE ON THIS PERFECT STORM
OF ISSUES THAT AFFECT EVERYBODY.
NOW, THE KEY FOR REPUBLICANS,
THOUGH, IS ONCE THEY WIN, WHICH
THEY WILL, TO LOCK IN THESE
GAINS, AND NOT WASTE IT AND DO
NOTHING AND BLOW IT, AND THEN
JUST, LIKE, HAVE THE SAME VOTERS
BE UP FOR GRABS NEXT CYCLE.
>> TWO THINGS.
ONE, SMORGASBORD, YOU PRO
ANNOUNCED THAT WELL.
IMPRESSIVE.
WE'RE SEEING HOW THAT WORKS OUT.
A COUPLE OF THINGS, I NOTICE
THAT DR. OZ IS TALKING LIKE A
MODERATE.
LET'S HAVE BALANCE.
LEE ZELDIN IS TALKING ABOUT
BALANCE TODAY.
THEY'RE SMART.
YOUNGKIN, I'M RUNNING AS A
CONSERVATIVE, BUT THE PEOPLE
THAT VOTE FOR ME ARE
INDEPENDENTS, AND DEMOCRATS HAVE
TO BE FEEL COMFORTABLE WITH ME.
THAT'S IMPORTANT.
YOU SAID TIM RYAN IS TALENTED.
WHEN TIM RYAN FIRST CAME IN, HE
TALKED LIKE KRISTIN CINEMA,
LOOKING TO MAKE DEALS, I'M FROMN
NANCY PELOSI.
HE VOTED AWAY FROM THE PARTY.
HE DIDN'T DO WHAT MANCHIN AND
CINEMA DID.
HE WANTS THEM TO ACCEPT HIM ACE
REPUBLICAN.
PEOPLE LIKE YOU ON THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, LIKE HE CLAIMS
TO BE, THIS IS THEIR
OPPORTUNITY, IF THE BLUE STATES
GET SMASHED, FREE THEM UP TO --
>> HE'S THE ONLY DEMOCRAT
RUNNING FOR THE U.S. SENATE,
OPENLY SAYING HE WISHES THAT JOE
BIDEN DOESN'T RUN IN 2024, THAT
HE WON'T SUPPORT HIM.
GIVE CREDIT WHERE CREDIT IS DUE.
>> ONCE IN A WHILE, IF HE STOOD
UP AND SAID THE INFLATION
REDUCTION ACT, I CAN'T SIGN OFF
ON THAT --
>> HE WATCHES "FOX AND FRIENDS,"
GIVE HIM CREDIT FOR THAT.
>> THERE'S NO OTHER CHOICE.
HAVE YOU FLIPPED AROUND IN THE
MORNING?
THERE'S NO OTHER CHOICE.
>> THAT'S WHAT I DO IN THE
MAKEUP ROOM, GET READY FOR
"NEWSROOM," THROW A FEW BACK AND
GET READY.
>> YOU'VE NEVER THROWN A FEW
BACK.
>> WATCH ME.
WE'RE JUST GETTING STARTED ON
"THE FIVE" AS WE COUNT DOWN TO
THE FIRST POLLS CLOSING.
STAY WITH FOX NEWS ALL FIGHT.
DEMOCRACY 2022 SPECIAL COVERAGE
STARTS RIGHT AT 6:00 P.M.
EASTERN.
WE'LL HAVE ALL T